as usual there's a lot of great new
stuff heading to Netflix in April and
we've cherry picked the best of the best
out of the streaming Giants list of
upcoming releases from apocalyptic
horror to quirky indie comedies here are
the best Netflix releases for April 2019
based on the 1960s Japanese show
ultraman is an updated take on the giant
robot warrior hero changing the style
from live-action to gorgeous 3d that
will no doubt offer plenty of
opportunity to showcase ultraman's
ambitious storylines the Netflix show
takes its story from a manga that began
in 2011 which introduces the son of the
original ultraman taking up the mantle
of the hero to defend the earth remember
how each episode of the original series
climaxed with a giant monster fight that
threatened to destroy towns cities and
sometimes even entire stretches of empty
woodland it'll be a lot like that but
instead of rubber suits and miniatures
Netflix's ultraman will be action on a
cosmic scale my wish was heard I guess
Ultraman transforms a Netflix on April
1st the first part of the chilling
Adventures of Sabrina was one of the
most anticipated new Netflix shows of
October 2018 starring Kiernan Shipka is
the half-witch Sabrina Spellman the show
quickly dove into some dark corners of
Sabrina's world the second parts of the
chilling Adventures of Sabrina is bound
to offer just as much intrigue and if
the latest trailer is any indication
it's going even darker than the first
part it's set to be be winched on April
5th through eye-opening documentaries
like the living planets life and planned
at Earth the BBC has introduced the
natural world to millions all of it
accompanied by the distinctive narration
of David Attenborough very impressive
but no one is watching with our planets
the team that created BBC's planets
earth is set to deliver another
breathtaking glimpse into the wild world
that most people never get a chance to
see and David Attenborough is back as
the narrator to guide us through it all
if you're a fan of nature documentaries
make sure you tune in for our planets on
April 5th in its first two seasons
Netflix's period series / documentary
Roman Empire didn't
actly blow anyone away with its
historical accuracy it's composed of a
strange sometimes jarring mashup of
History Channel style documentary
Talking Heads in all mixed with dramatic
reenactments
but while the mix of history and drama
isn't for everyone there's no doubt that
Roman Empire is entertaining the third
season will focus on Emperor Caligula
and is sure to offer plenty for fans to
enjoy travel back in time when Caligula
the mad emperor debuts on April 5th the
acting team of brie Larson and samuel
l.jackson may seem like a recent
development but the two have actually
shared plenty of screen time over the
years after appearing together in
calling Skull Island Jackson signed up
for a role in Larson's directorial debut
unicorn store the film is about a
middle-aged woman who's going through a
personal crisis when a mysterious man
invites her to a unicorn store or
something although it was released in
2017 unicorn store fell off the radar
after its premiere at the Toronto
International Film Festival
fortunately the store didn't close its
doors for good because Netflix later
picked up the distribution rights take a
look and figure out what's what - when
unicorn store opens on April 5th Netflix
is upcoming you versus Wilde is sort of
a mash-up of man vs. wild and black
mirror Bandersnatch which offered a
modern-day update on the choose your own
adventure story format in Bandersnatch
viewers were presented with options that
dictated where the story went so picture
that but with you getting to decide at
Bear Grylls jumps off a waterfall or
uses an old tree to climb down or
whatever
[Music]
it's aimed at the younger audience but
if Netflix can pull it off you versus
wild could easily shape up to be a lot
of fun for people of all ages take the
leap on April 10th say what you will
about zombies but they just won't stay
dead black summer is supposed to be the
next big zombie series on the small
screen taking audiences back to the
opening days of a zombie apocalypse set
to be a spin-off to sci-fi zombies shows
znation
black summer has a lot of potential for
fans of the genre basically it's the
same apocalypse spud with different
characters take a look when black summer
arrives on April 11 based on the 2015
novel The Silence probably has a
familiar premise to anyone who's seen a
quiet place a group of people are trying
to stay alive in a world infested by
monsters who hunt by sound but surface
similarities aside there are a lot of
new ideas in the silence that are going
to make it worth watching the story
centers on a young woman played by
Sabrina's Kiernan Shipka who winds up on
the wrong side of a gang of cultists
check it out on April 12 set in Istanbul
the protector is about a man who gains
mystical powers through a magical shirt
and becomes the protector of the city
but as the opening shot explains this
is no fairy tale the first 10 episodes
season of the protector dropped in
December 2018 to positive reviews which
was good news for Netflix since they had
already ordered a second season of the
show look for that to hit on April 26th
out of all the myths that have sprung up
over the years about famous musicians
the story of blues musician Robert
Johnson meeting the devil at a
Mississippi crossroads is one of the
most fascinating as the legend goes
Johnson took his guitar and went out to
the crossroads at midnight where the
devil tuned his guitar for him and gave
him the blues iasts kills in the country
in exchange for his soul obviously
that's all just a myth but Netflix's
upcoming remastered devil at the
crossroads will dig into the story as
well as the real facts surrounding
johnson's life death and music look for
it on April 26 for foodies the Netflix
cooking show chef's table came in like
an 8 course dinner mouth-watering and
satisfying now the creators of chef's
table are back with an all-new travel
and cooking docu-series called Street
food as the title suggests the team will
tour the globe to focus on the unsung
masters of these street-level culinary
feasts most of the details about the
show are still marinating in secrecy so
we'll just have to wait to hear more
about how street food will pan out we do
know that you'll be able to dig in when
the series debuts on Netflix on April
26th fans of the supernatural will
definitely have the most to look forward
to this April in addition to continuing
series like the chilling Adventures of
Sabrina and the protector Netflix will
be debuting an all-new supernatural
horror show called chambers although
Netflix hasn't released many details for
chambers yet the premise is intriguing
after a girl undergoes a heart
transplant her personality takes a dark
turn she comes to find out that she's
manifesting the characteristics of her
hearts donor it's a plot so original
we've never seen it before
well at least since that one time they
did it on an episode of Erie Indiana in
1991
I think it's my heart she was kind of
weird take a look when Chambers
premieres sometime in April
keep your eyes peeled for two new
stand-up comedy specials this month
first we'll be graced with yet another
Kevin Hart special in irresponsable
debuting on April 2nd at the end of the
month you'll be able to laugh at the dry
comedy and Anthony Jeselnik fire in the
maternity ward look for that on April
30th that does it for the best Netflix
originals Landing in April two thousand
nineteen so let's turn to the other
great movies you can look forward to
next month
Netflix is list of new action films is
slim but it's full of winners on the
first look for snatch I am Legend and
Valkyrie a world war two action thriller
starring Tom Cruise as the Nazi Colonel
who led an assassination plot against
Hitler also don't miss the cult sci-fi
action extravaganza the Fifth Element
we'll put it this way if you've never
seen it you have no idea what you're
missing you'll also get slashers galore
in April with Freddy vs. Jason Friday
the 13th and Texas Chainsaw 3d while
most of Netflix's films are arriving in
a single dump on the first the drama
section will be spread out over the
course of the month tune in for classics
like all the President's Men and Bonnie
and Clyde on March first followed by the
hateful eight to the extended version on
April 25th because the three-hour
theatrical version just wasn't long
enough there are even a few gems hiding
in Netflix as comedy releases for April
if you haven't seen 2001 evolution
that's definitely worth a watch if for
no other reason than to see what this
bit is all about and of course you can't
go wrong with pineapple Express the
blockbuster comedy from Judd Apatow
about a group of stoners who get in way
over their head after witnessing a
murder look for both of those on the
first of the month check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite movies
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]